serais pas étonné franz-olivier giesbert
que je fais à six unités review fromage
ou dessert culture ou dépendance
je choisis tout comme disait saint
thérèse de lisieux ben alors à la
culture des racines des ailes
dl chirac ou mitterrand se trouve h se
trouve âge parce que j'adore et
mitterrand je me jette dire chirac parce
qu'il est vivant mais tu aurais
mitterrand j'adore et mitterrand je
reçois côté canadien mais les deux sont
tout de suite de ce drame et de chirac
ou mitterrand s'était les interviews
qu'il fallait pas faire résister ci ra
quo mitterrand où vous avez vos
questions vaches la foire était là j'ai
un bout de chaque michak michak sarkozy
ou villepin sarkozy panafieu ou de la
noël bernard debré royal ou hollande
ils sont bien tous les deux alors
l'objet de réponses jospin mais
pourquoi vous avez vous en tirez
répondant à chaque fois quelqu'un daury
le public jugera mais sur le côté ou ray
au milieu hommage sur le côté thé ou
café café garçons ou filles 1 fille
alcoologue alcool ou drogue alcool
20-20-20 pétards ou cigares cigare mais
je fume pas gauche droite gauche figaro
ou libération
pire à sion vous vous enfoncez gill a
été au nouvel obs et ensuite au figaro
magazine c'est vrai que je comprends que
vous avez vu mes initiales fog way
brouillard brouillard mais les
journalistes ont-ils des convictions
non non non mais attendez j'ai des
convictions ça n'a rien à voir passer à
autre chose à voir dans les débats
politiques voyez france 2 ou france 3
france 3 je travaille dieu où diable bon
dieu quand même mort ou vivant vivant
verlaine rimbaud se ses vaches et quand
même un beau il est meilleur regret ou
remords progrès heureux ou malheureux re
rebelles ou provocateur rebelles chien
ou chat chat beatles aux rolling stones
en ligne stone selon moi c'était le rôle
historique sans marilyn manson marilyn
monroe par une mode raw jeanne d'arc ou
mireille darc georges honda mais j'aime
beaucoup mieux fait chair rouge au
chèvre c'était un animal merveilleux
tellement intelligent coca ou pepsi coca
ville ou campagne campagne nucléaire ou
solaires solaire cigale ou fourmi cigale
lève tôt au couche-tard lève tôt
villas ou appartements villas lennon
mccartney lemon mer ou montagne merde
piercing ou tatouage et les piercings et
les barbus tatouages
les corrections de ne rien rater de in a
l'habitude abonnez vous mettez un pouce
bleus